i am a huge fan of when you uh partner  up with derek cena france oh and i know  that uh you guys i have talked about  doing wolfman  is that happening what is it about that  project and getting to work with him  again that is like i want to do this  we're working on it um you know i just  would do anything with derek but like  the idea of doing something like that  just seems really exciting you know it's  it's new for both of us but it's um in  some way i feel like it's  it's kind of the movie we've we've made  already a few times but like in in a in  but but but in literal form you know  we've always kind of made the  metaphorical version of it and it's sort  of like the opportunity to really to  just make the literal version of what  what we've been hacking away at  so um i i've always loved that character  he's just just an all-time character  just just has always been like  you know on a bucket list for me so i i  i hope we we can do it but you know we  got to get it right